they're ready
they're willing and they're coming to a
town
near you these are york city's
street rangers the government's covet
marshals
will do a very similar sort of job the
street ranges
as a whole are just that friendly face
for people to approach within new york
city centre
we're not so much getting a lot of
questions coming to us it's more people
pointing out about other people not
really following the social distancing
what sort of reaction are you getting
when you are reminding people about
social distancing
that's majority of the time it's
positive a private company runs the
street ranges
it'll be councils who organise covered
marshals
but they'll share one key restriction
they can't enforce rules
they need the police for that and really
that's what's provoked the biggest
criticism of this plan
with police forces saying that they are
simply baffled
by the idea of a covid marshall they've
questioned how effective they will be
when they can only advise and not
enforce
if it's a group of people who already
don't care and we're congregating beyond
you know
in bigger groups than they're supposed
to if they've got like if they're not
the police then they can't really do
that much
they're gonna need a little bit of just
people they're reminding them to do this
to do that
you can't stop people by enforcing any
law or anything and find them
but if you educate them there might be
some difference
the government's new rule of six might
at least make it easier to spot when
people aren't following the rules
this will be the last weekend that laura
york's restaurant can hold a party
this big we have had two contact
bookings ahead of time
and and and explain that we can't
accommodate them
people have been very understanding the
rule of six
may last for months it's impact felt
everywhere
meet the preston family dad ian twins
sienna and talia
hugo and india when mom claire and
oldest daughter maya are home
they make seven they need to lose two
to meet just one other person i think
it's gonna be a lot of difficult choices
i mean christmas still feels like quite
a long time away doesn't it
um but people like to get organized so
yeah we'll just have to wait and see
what happens it's gonna be interesting
no doubt claire and i are gonna have to
have
a bit of a chat about whose parents
we're gonna see and with the number of
cases rising up to close to 3 000 a day
at the moment
i think all of us need to keep eyes on
the prize really
and that is that we need to keep the
infections under control
the prime minister described the new
restrictions as heartbreaking to
implement
they may be even tougher to enforce
catherine patosi sky news in york